cuál es la importancia de llevar a cabo
la reunión justo ahora en momentos en
que los países como eeuu india japón y
australia pasan por un momento muy bajo
en sus relaciones con china
buen dia andrés este es realmente algo
muy notable en el proceso que se está
dando en eeuu ahora retomar rápidamente
en lo que sería la primera acción
multilateral que está haciendo vaivén
hacia el exterior es con el cual creo
que sea como el significativo para todo
lo que es la política
'el indio' pacífica fundamentalmente
recordemos que es esto
este es un foro estratégico informal no
hay una agenda entre estados unidos
japón india y australia que organiza
cumbres regulares intercambio y
formación y actualmente organiza
ejercicios militares
justamente en febrero de este año parte
del jugado había organizado una
conferencia o un mitin contra oa favor
perdón en este caso de una mayor
profundización de la democracia en
birmania muy cercana a pekín es
realmente notable que hoy biden empiece
este tipo de relaciones a nivel
multinacional o multilateral con con
esto y es muy significativo en ese
sentido carlos de qué manera busca esta
nueva alianza contrarrestar la
influencia
china en la región de asia-pacífico y
qué tan efectiva sería esta iniciativa
muy buena pregunta esta es la primera
vez que se va a intentar profundizar en
situaciones prácticas en este caso van a
tratar temas de cambio climático la
pandemia naturalmente la seguridad que
es parte del proceso de lo que se está
elaborando dentro del cual chinas y
fundamentalmente vieron una novedad
interesante el financiamiento este a
india de las vacunas para las empresas
subsidiarias de nuevo a bucks y de
johnson y johnson que es algo que de
alguna forma pone a china en un entre
dictó ya que ellos también están
aumentando su capacidad de producción de
vacunas por el coronavirus
carlos como cree que china tomara esta
reunión vamos hacia la conformación de
un nuevo bloque de alianza militar como
ocurrió cuando se creó la otan para
frenar la influencia en rusia
andrés realmente la pregunta también es
excelente recordemos que ya japón y
australia tienen una alianza militar en
ese caso ya declarada ya establecida de
complementaridad desde hace unos años
recordemos además que japón y eeuu desde
1969 tienen un acuerdo para el tema
militar de las islas social eeuu
protegería japón y justamente lo que se
está dando entre japón y china es un
problema con una isla y al thani el mar
de japón si vamos aún no está o no creo
que el tiempo nos lo dirá china hoy de
alguna forma mira esto como si fuera un
otan y busca de alguna forma acercarse
un poco más a rusia como forma de
contrarrestar esto rusia todavía no se
ha manifestado o se manifiesta
ciertamente dudosa para este tipo de
situaciones lo que hace que esta
situación se ponga un poco más difícil
fundamentalmente en esa parte del mundo
es muy poca la información que para este
lado del mundo nos viene relacionado con
esto pero es una es un tema de larga
data del 2007 hasta ahora se han
efectuado este intercambios creo que el
más importante que tenemos es el del
noviembre del 2020 donde japón y eeuu
organizan ejercicios militares y eso
creo que puso a china en una situación
de por lo menos de contemplación de esta
situación